on nous dit vous aussi vous avez une
recette c'est un dessert je me dis
chocolat non non c'était pas un enfin ce
n'est pas exactement on pourrait presque
le faire comme un dessert c'est une
recette qui m'a été communiquée pendant
la guerre de entre 40 et 44
en fait c'est parce qu'un jeu vous voyez
j'ai fait chauffer de l'eau là c'est
tout simple selon des nouilles au
chocolat alors c'est une
recette qui m'a été communiquée par un
camarade
et voilà nous est enfin pour vous
expliquer c'est que pendant gtj 3
pendant la guerre est alors j'avais
droit à une ration de chocolat à tous
les mois une ration qui vient d'ailleurs
aucun rapport avec tout chocolat qu'on
m'a mis là donc là on ne faudra pas
tenir compte on peut je n'avais que
c'est alors je rencontre cet ami qui est
je lui dis je vais toucher ma ration de
chocolat et alors il y vient avec my je
touche ma ration il y avait de deux
petites choses de chocolat tout petit il
me dit c'est idiot delannoy de manger
ton chocolat comme ça bêtement comme un
goinfre de petites choses comme ça tu
ferais mieux pour bien en faire usage de
deleuze et en servir comme ingrédient
est de faire une chose qui est
formidable ce sont les nouilles au
chocolat je vais vous démontrer comment
on fait ces fameuses new york à la fédé
nous oui là il faut déduire vous voyez
vous faites bouillir de l'eau ça pendant
la guerre on pouvait y avait encore des
pattes de temps en temps voyez vous
mettiez vos pâtes là le relâche pas pour
la bonne et moi j'étais tout seul mais
je m'endette effet pour au moins une
semaine j'avais pris tout n'est pas de
trois mois et j'avais fait ça voyez là
je pense q peut-on faire je peux pas
vous dire pour le nombre de personnes en
tout cas ah oui ils ont mais qu'il faut
mettre un peu de gros sel noter qu'il
faut en mettre un peu plus avec le
chocolat chez pas
voilà alors pour 4 personnes c'est 250
grammes peut-être 250 g en fait j'en
sais rien alors on va attendre alors
pendant ce temps là vous prenez votre
chocolat voyez vous avez mettez une
goutte au un tout petit peu et alors là
c'est selon bat cependant regehr
évidemment que ça représentait à peine
une chose comme ça alors vous mettez là
je ne sais pas si j'ai allumé la ici
mais ça a l'air d'allumer alors c'est
selon la
jeune est appuyé selon le nombre de
personnes qu'il y a dans la famille et
je commence déjà à mettre un petit peu
de un petit peu de beurre 1
voit comme ça
riez un jeu tout y avec délicatesse 1
voilà
mais alors vous voyez ce camarade débat
briller ça commence à prendre tournure
là ça commence
je lis rien disait j'ai réalisé pendant
la guerre puis hier fois une fois une
fois
j'ai réalisé pendant la guerre une fois
et
enfin vous allez voir vous allez goûter
tout de suite après je dois dire que
ce n'est pas simplement qu'une recette
culinaire c'est un souvenir que lance un
souvenir que l'on garde
regarde toute sa vie se souvenir des
nouilles au chocolat
alors bon donc évidemment ça je suis pas
très très grand grecs 1 dans le problème
de fond passer des pâtes mais enfin ça y
est tout de même bon à part ça je je je
le mets là je fais égoutter les pâtes
bons jeux les jeux je les prépare je les
mets ici là ça me semble très bien les
deux parties et je vais refaire encore
un petit peu de
la voilà ça démarre très bien
ça vous plaît comme c'est très curieux
mais c'est intéressant
pour les familles nombreuses c'est très
bien mais ça peut parce que c'est à la
fois comique et puis ça pesé non mais
c'est drôle parce que ça peut c'est une
recette n'est pas celle pour servir la
frais de légumes et de desserts oui
c'est très beau et puis c'est très très
très droitier qui s'appelait beaucoup
d'enfants je pense
aller alors la bresle alors là vous
voyez là c'est l'opération est
évidemment là c'est dragon et
voilà
alors là on en arrive au sénat
immédiatement adore la sans tarder vous
voyez immédiatement tout sur les pattes
eu le geste abri à bas bruit évidemment
et puis alors la gouaille et tout de
suite on tourne alors ça vous fait de
merveilleuses nouilles au chocolat
des
rappels ça me rajeunit pas ce que ça
fait ce terreau 40
3 je crois ad je vais arrêter là parce
que sa cliente a fumé
et alors ça me rajeunit de je ne sais
pas quand même temps
au départ c
il faut dire la vérité c'est
ça fait drôle n'est ce pas voilà
bah moi je peux pas mieux vous dire
voulez-vous goûter je vais attendre un
petit peu si vous voulez bien doivent
être chaude la non mais je vais goûter
c'est promis enfin je veux des goodies
et enfin vraiment moi je crois que c'est
un plat c'est un choix intéressant est
en tout cas comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il il laisse un très grand
souvenir dans la vie d'un d'un individu
et croyez moi que si vous le donner à
votre famille ils s'en souviendront
[Rires]
[Musique]